hello everyone today we're going to
learn how a solar cell is able to turn
light generated mobile charges into
electricity today's lesson will use
everything we've learned in the past
videos to understand this effect so make
sure you understand the material from
the previous videos before watching
first let's go over the structure of a
solar cell here's a cell that I made and
we can see that a metal ribbon is
connected to top metal contacts which
form a grid the spaces between the
gridlines allow light to enter the cell
if we flip over the cell we see the
entire back surface is coated with metal
which allows easy extraction of charge
from the back surface additionally we
have another metal ribbon that is
connected to the backside now let's look
up our solar cell to an ammeter to
measure the current so here we have an
ammeter connected to our solar cell and
our light source which will simulate the
Sun and we can see that if we turn on
our light source we start to read a
current flowing out of our solar cell in
this case about 0.12 amps or 120 milli
amps now if we turn off the light the
output of the cell drops to zero and we
no longer read any current we know from
our last demo that light generates
mobile charges in silicon but how do
these mobile charges become electric
current coming out of our solar cell the
secret has to do with doping the top
layer is doped with phosphorus shown in
blue while the bottom layer is doped
with boron shown in red the different
dopants interact in a way which will
describe shortly to create an electric
field in our device with the boron doped
in phosphorus doped regions meet it is
this electric field that acts as a
one-way valve in our solar cell for
electrons and holes an electric field is
created when positive and negative
charges are separated as you know
opposite charges attract and like
charges repel will exploit this property
by creating a sheet of positive charges
on the left and negative charges on the
right thus producing an electric field
which we denote with the Greek letter Z
if you were to insert a negatively
charged particle such as an electron
into this field it would move toward the
positive charges alternatively if you
put a positively charged particle it
would move toward the negative charges
we were able to create an electric field
inside our solar cell by using different
dopants on either side of the device
here we have our silicon lattice which
is undoped we'll start by replacing some
of the silicon atoms with phosphorus
atoms on one side on the opposite side
we'll put in boron atoms to focus on our
dopant atoms and the mobile charges they
introduced will fade out the silicon
lattice recall that phosphorus atoms
introduce static positive charges in
mobile negative charges while boron
atoms introduce static negative charges
in mobile positive charges all the
mobile charges are free to move around
at random a process known as diffusion
here we see a single electron moving
around on its random walk during this
random motion if an electron and hole
encounter each other they neutralize and
effectively vanish as this process of
holes and electrons randomly diffusing
and neutralizing at the interface
continues the total number of mobile
charges in the device decreases this
leaves a region at the interface of
immobile static charges with the net
charge is negative on one side and
positive on the other these opposing
sheets of charge create an electric
field of the interface which at this
point is very weak as charges continue
to diffuse they are still able to move
across this weak electric field and
neutralize as this happens the sheets of
net positive and negative static charges
widen and the electric field grows in
strength now that the electric field is
stronger as other mobile charges
continue to move and diffuse around the
lattice they are now repelled by the
field an electron stay to the left and
hole stay to the right
it is this electric field that separates
light generated mobile charges and
pushes them to the extreme ends of the
device the image we see now is our solar
cell in the dark however recall that our
silicon atoms are still present and if
light strikes our silicon atom a mobile
hole and electron is generated as these
mobile charges move around randomly
there's a chance that they will randomly
encounter the electric field the mobile
electron will get repelled by the
electric
however the mobile hole will get swept
to the other side by the electric field
now let's zoom out we can see that after
the electric field has pushed our light
excited electron and hole to the left
and right respectively
we now have an extra negative charge on
the left and an extra positive charge on
the right if we connect a wire to short
the two opposite sides together the
excess electrons are attracted to the
excess holes on the opposite side this
attraction is what drives electricity
through our wire as light continually
shines on the solar cell charges are
constantly being pushed out of the
device and driving the electric current
now hopefully you understand the basics
of how these amazing but rather simple
devices work we hope that this knowledge
will provide the basic foundation while
tackling more difficult and abstract
concepts while you learn the material in
this course I'm Joe Sullivan thanks for
watching